Democrats have changed a bill making its
way through the Nevada legislature that
would have initially allowed a person to
sue over private property eight news now
investigator David charns breaks down
the debate over the homeless person's
Bill of Rights
this proposal is among the bills with
the most public comments so far this
session most things in this homeless
Bill of Rights aren't controversial at
all it's symbolic saying those
experiencing homelessness have rights to
dignity medical treatment to not be
discriminated against by an employer
because they don't have a permanent
address another part says a homeless
person can sue somebody who violates
those rights bills sponsor Democratic
state senator Dallas Harris says the
goal is to make sure the homeless
population knows they have rights like
everybody else Republicans say there's
no need to legislate that it is designed
to let the homeless people of Nevada
know
that here in this state
they are entitled to the same rights as
every other resident of this state
no more
and no less
and I really want to emphasize the no
less I don't know how you
can legally Force dignity and respect
into the law I understand the concept
but do we have laws now that we're
trying to change that deny them dignity
and respect several public commenters
said they didn't want to see Nevada or
Las Vegas turn into a city like San
Francisco which of course is dealing
with a spike in homelessness a census
here last year found more than 5 000
people experiencing homelessness in
shelters and streets across the Las
Vegas Valley with concerns that number
is growing now this Senate Bill had its
first public hearing Friday of course
with three months left in the session it
has a long way to go and it's unclear
what its next steps will be near Desert
Inn in Paradise I'm David charns 8 News
Now